signify so the peppers at the very
bottom represent how like intense the
games are so how much like you need to
get into them so like a ball count when
you're just like tilting it back and
forth you're not using much action or
safe crack but then games where you like
getting up and dancing those are gonna
have more pepper ketchup so fake draw is
they spin on off of a quick-draw where
you're gonna be listening for the cue to
fire but they're gonna try to throw
other words that start with F to try to
make you shoot early for football right
[Music]
so are you left you ready I'm already
ready okay yeah there you go
so once you're ready just go ahead and
pull the truck your hands down until you
hear the word fire fire nice after the
last one was friends I would love to one
more same game see if you can beat the
champ yeah that's right
you got three good ears that's good
though they may be in your meter but I
can listen
that project like Trey Parker know you
guys can try to fake each other out so
we don't have to play by the rules you
know ready steady fire fury there's a
lot of fun yeah that's fun wow I just
yeah couple thank you so much guys to
bring this by